foreign.
[Silence]
foreign
Huh?
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the
chapter regarding
the various types oful which are
preferred.
Now
we have listed thus far three types of
which are preferred.
The author here goes into a fourth which
I believe is probably rather obscure,
rather unknown or less known.
And
being that it is less known, I doubt
that many of us will ever encounter
this. However, it is something that is
an occurrence that did happen in the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's time
and
therefore it is listed on the off
chance that someone may have this
particular
scenario occur.
Here
[Silence]
the author tells us bathing
after burying a disbeliever. believer.
Now, this is a very obscure instance.
And what is meant by bathing after
burying a disbeliever is that a person
physically is the one that does the
burying.
Now
it is essentially
impermissible for the believer to bury
the disbeliever unless in an obscure
instance where the Muslim is the direct
descendant, the direct heir and directly
responsible
for burying
this particular person. And the instance
that the author here cites is the
narration of
and this is regarding when his father
passed away. Now a person may see this
and say well this is an evidence that it
is permissible for a Muslim to bury a
non-Muslim or for a Muslim to attend
a funeral of a non-Muslim. But had that
been the case would the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam not have
attended his uncle's funeral?
He would have been the first to attend.
Correct. If any disbeliever
was worthy of having his funeral
attended by the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam, it would be the it would be
Abu Talib due to his extensive history
in defending the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
Right? due to his extensive history in
defending the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. However, he did not attend his
funeral. He did not bathe him. He did
not interact with his body. He went to
him as he was passing away. He
you know invited him to Islam there
at his bedside in his final moments. But
he left it at that. After Abu Talib
passed away, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam never saw him again. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has prohibited that
a Muslim make dua
of forgiveness for a person who has died
upon disbelief.
For a person who has died upon
disbelief.
This is with respect to Ibraim.
This is with respect to Abu Talib. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down the verse
in the ending and closing verses of
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
He says,
[Silence]
and and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in the closing verses of
it is not permissible.
This is the exact translation. Actually
the translation
would be more
correct. It is not permissible and
not fit. It is inappropriate
for the prophet and the believers, those
who believe, to seek forgiveness on
behalf of the disbelievers, on behalf of
the mushri, even if they are of family
after it has been made clear to them
that they are of the people of the
hellfire. How is it that it becomes
clear to a person when someone else is
of the people of the hellfire? How do we
know that?
Say
dying upon disbelief. Right? When a
person is offered Islam, they reject
Islam, they die upon disbelief. We know
otherwise how can we know? We wouldn't
know other than this because in a
person's lifetime they may change.
However, in a person's death when they
die upon a particular religion, this is
an indication that this person has
their their time has been sealed and it
will not change. And so in this verse,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made it
impermissible
to make and seek forgiveness on behalf
of those who die upon disbelief,
even if they are family members.
Even if they are family members.
And
an important point here is that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam did not
know this prior to his
uncle dying upon disbelief prior to the
death of Abu Talib. And Abu Talib died
in which year?
Which year did Abu Talib die? He died in
the 10th year? The 10th year after
prophethood. when he passed away, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down this verse
in
he sent down another verse of
so when Abu Talib died and these verses
were revealed
who came to the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam and informed him
met Abu Talib has died has passed away.
He said take his body and bury it.
Now what does this mean? Take his body
and bury it. Is his body bathed? Is it
to be bathed? No. Is it to be shrouded?
No. Not in this way. They are not buried
under the rights of the Muslim. Now Ali
was the only one around to bury him.
Why? Well
is his son and the people of Quraysh the
Mushri of Quraysh were in open war
against Abu Talib. they were in very
heightened
you know state of aggression between
him and Abu Talib and therefore no one
else was around to bury him and so Ali
was forced to do so. He went and he
buried him. He was a young boy at the
time. He said
He said, "And then after I buried him, I
returned back to him and informed him
that I had buried him. And he said to
me, bathe,
bathe." And so from this we get this
instance. This is a very as I mentioned
very obscure situation
very unlikely that a person will be in
such an instance unless a person's
parents are non-Muslim they die as
non-Muslims and they don't have other
family members to bury them or they
don't have anyone else anyone who will
bury them in this case the person would
oversee the burial But with the
situation of Ali, he is the one who
physically buried the body.
This is extremely unlikely for for one
of us. Even if they had similar familial
situation
unless they happened to be a gravedigger
too and they happen to be a mortician
too. So for every Muslim who has
non-Muslim family
that have no other family
and he happens to be a mortician, an
undertaker and he happens to be a
gravedigger then he needs to bathe after
this instance. But this is about as rare
as they say in Arabic.
This is about you know as rare as
climbing a tree and finding a cow up
there at the top of the tree hanging
out. This is extremely unlikely
situation but it is there
and the scholars list it
and mention it for the purpose of
posterity.
[Arabic recitation]